maximum au tribunal d'auch mais sous un
amas remercièrent d'un justin smoak sur
le tas il réclame la libération de son
ami 6
après l'électrochoc de carpentras la
droite modérée formation unis contre
l'extrême droite dans plusieurs villes
de france le front national est mise en
quarantaine
l'athlé site est au centre d'un congrès
de psychiatrie à paris portrait d'un
comédien aveugle une notion de courage
enfin à trois jours des élections et
yann eliès tout pareil maintenant être
le futur homme fort en roumanie les
sondages le donnent grand vainqueur à
19h30 portrait réalisé par nos envoyés
spéciaux une caresse
bonsoir nous vous donnions la nouvelle
dès 19 heures un jeune homme armé a pris
en otage deux magistrats de juge pour
enfants au palais de justice de mai cet
après-midi les précisions de morad aït
habbouche à l'intérieur du palais de
justice au troisième étage exactement un
homme est armé depuis le début d'après
midi 15 heures environ il tient en joue
deux juges d'instruction deux femmes du
tribunal pour enfants
il s'agit de catherine bourassin et
marie-hélène pomarède
selon les premiers éléments recueillis
sur place il a un pistolet de gros
calibre
ce preneur d'otages dont on ignore
l'identité serait âgé d'une vingtaine
d'années seulement il est grand et
maigre ce qu'ils demandent la libération
de sa petite amie en garde à vue depuis
qu'elle 24 heures le préfet de la
moselle est toujours en contact avec le
kidnappeur mais aucune information n'a
filtré un pc opérationnel a été mis en
place
et même si à l'extérieur la présence
policière est discrète
un groupe d'intervention de la police
nationale est arrivée sur les lieux
on ne sait pas si risque ou non
d'intervenir visiblement les autorités
souhaitent privilégier les négociations
notre correspondant à metz bernard derty
qui nous a donné la nouvelle à 19h nous
appellera sans doute au cours de ce
journal le dauphiné libéré publiera
demain dans son numéro de vendredi un
témoignage anonyme liés à la profanation
du cimetière de carpentras le
correspondant qui a refusé de donner son
identité affirment être passé par hasard
près du cimetière dans la nuit du 8 mai
il a vu un véhicule sans doute une
mercedes immatriculée dans la seine
quant à l'enquêté sur la profanation du
cimetière juif de clichy et semblent
progresser les dix personnes ont été
interpellées elles sont interrogés
depuis ce matin par les policiers
ces suspects sont tous proches des
milieux d'extrême droite
reportage à clichy sous bois fer 3
ile-de-france commentaire hervé dino la
police entrepris une véritable plongée
dans les milieux d'extrême droite pour
retrouver les auteurs de la profanation
de clichy ce matin une dizaine de
personnes ont rejoint les trois
individus qui était placé depuis la
veille
garde à vue dans les locaux de la
brigade criminelle tout ce petit monde
appartient à la mouvance des partis néo
nazis et tout particulièrement du parti
nationaliste français et européens le
pnf eux qui s'est illustré en 88 par
plusieurs attentats contre le magazine
globe et les foyers sonacotra inculpés
dans le cadre de cette affaire serge
lecanu le secrétaire général du pnd feu
a été relâché il y à un mois et demi
claude cornu où le président du
mouvement est lui toujours derrière les
barreaux
affaibli par ces arrestations le pm et
feu serait aujourd'hui hébergée dans un
immeuble de clichy par le comité
soutient un autre europe
une publication qui fut longtemps
l'organe de la fane un autre parti
d'extrême droite dirigé par marc
frederix n est dissout en 1981 après une
vague d'attentats anti sémite
manifestement dans cette affaire les
services de police ont décidé de
ratisser très large en plaçant en garde
à vue des personnes simplement
soupçonnées d'être des sympathisants de
partis d'extrême droite quitte à les
relâcher très rapidement à l'heure
actuelle la brigade criminelle poursuit
activement ses investigations et il
n'est pas exclu que non la prochaine
heure elle procède à de nouvelles
interpellations à royan après
l'agression d'un professeur d'histoire
en début de semaine enquête a
véritablement démarré les policiers
entendent est aujourd'hui les dix-huit
familles des élèves de christine dia et
ce matin le proviseur du collège la
russie à son tour des menaces le point
sur l'enquêté ont rejoint tout de suite
sur place dominique chappuit non nouveau
aujourd'hui à royan ce sont les menaces
reçus hier par le frère du principal du
collège émile-zola un mystérieux
interlocuteur anonyme en effet téléphoné
au frère de henri bouillet qui habite la
cité balnéaire en pensant en touche et
le principal du collège qui lui loge
dans une commune voisine et crie le
menaçant quelqu'un de ma famille portant
mon nom dans des termes évidemment ses
voisins
les basques avaient reçu maladie à
l'audition des dix-huit familles de
parents d'élèves s'est poursuivie toute
la journée
l'essentiel pour les enquêteurs
déterminer si les adolescents ont parlé
de secours autour d'eux on va tout
simplement demandé si j'avais eu écho du
cours dispensés par le professeur en
question et comme je n'avais pas vu
christelle à la sortie des cours j'ai
répondu que non
on en a parlé le samedi à midi quand ils
sont rentrés
voilà qui vous ont dit ils m'ont donc
dit m'expliquer pour le coup de prague
quoi ce que leur avait expliqué c'était
pas courant mais je trouve ça bien parce
que c'est bien de parler de l'actualité
en fin de matinée un représentant du
ministère de l'éducation nationale s'est
rendu au collège il est venu apporter un
message de solidarité de l'ensemble des
enseignants français face aux tentatives
d'intimidation ne peuvent que nous
renforcer dans le sentiment il faut
enseigner l'éducation civique et qu'il y
a des valeurs et les voleurs et la
démocratie et de la république et ses
valeurs s'enseigne demain le recteur de
l'académie de poitiers assurera à royan
le cours de madame guillard les
profanations sont désormais si fréquenté
les risques d'agression d'affrontements
si réel que les hommes politiques
modérés ont décidé de redoubler de
vigilance
ainsi françois mitterrand cours de son
voyage en polynésie a de nouveau lancé
un appel à la tolérance zéro propose de
l'écouter il faut se voir maintenir
entre vous se plie ma de confiance et de
tolérance et je voudrais bien que cette
leçon de tolérance soit entendu bien au
delà de chez vous qu'est ce tu entendu
jusqu'à la lointaine métropole un peuple
n'est fort que s'ils restent unis dans
le respect de ses propres différents et
pour montrer leur bonne volonté
autrement dit pour tenter d'apaiser le
débat les socialistes ont décidé de
retirer l'une de leurs propositions qui
suscitait une vive polémique
le bureau exécutif du ps ne proposera
plus ou du moins pour un certain temps
de donner le droit de vote aux immigrés
un changement de cap apparemment
apprécié par l'opposition qui demande
tout de même un engagement solennel des
socialistes reportage tania sportiello
il faut avoir du réalisme en politique
estiment les socialistes qui comme
pierre mauroy n'ont plus envie d' agiter
le chiffon rouge du vote des étrangers
en france
cette réforme durement combattu par
l'opposition demanderai une révision
constitutionnelle et la gauche
parlementaire c'est qu'elle n'a aucune
chance de la faire aboutir avec la
majorité requise des 3/5
pas question non plus d'envisager de
faire un référendum sur cette question
qui passe mal dans l'opinion et le ps a
préféré mettre le droit de vote des
étrangers en veilleuse alors un cadeau à
la droite s'agit pas du tout de cadeau à
la droite
il s'agit simplement de constater qu'une
mesure que nous souhaitons et qui un
jour entrera en vigueur mais un jour
plus tard il n'est pas réaliste il n'est
pas raisonnable de continuer à la
présenter tous les jours alors que nous
savons que dans l'immédiat
l'opinion française n'est pas prête à
l'accepter un report qui tombe bien en
tout cas à quelques jours d'un débat
parlementaire et d'une table ronde sur
l'immigration à matignon
l'opposition d'ailleurs n'a pas manqué
de réagir devant ce geste de bonne
volonté
s'il n'y avait pas eu cette décision de
prise
il n'y aurait eu certainement aucune
rencontre à matignon sur l'immigration
donc cette décision devrait permettre de
décrisper des choses de permettre cette
rencontre la boule voyait l'initiative
est apprécié par l'opposition qui tienne
elle aussi a donné un bon exemple
plusieurs maires de droite modérée ont
ainsi décidé de mettre en quarantaine le
front national en refusant de prêter ou
de louer la salle des fêtes à l'extrême
droite albert ripamonti un petit tour et
puis s'en va franç ais new girl anciens
waffen ss leader de l'extrême droite
allemande parade dans les rues de lyon
aux côtés du responsable local du front
national pur bravade
quelques jours auparavant le maire de la
ville l'a déclaré persona non grata
la connotation nazie est insupportable
dans la capitale de la résistance
explique michel noir le maire de lyon
donne ainsi le la aujourd'hui certaines
municipalités d'opposition lui emboîte
le pas tissant une sorte de cordon
sanitaire autour de jean marie le pen
dinard en bretagne angoulême c'est
maintenant au tour du maire udf de vichy
de refuser une salle au front national
date prévue du meeting le 29 septembre
prochains jours précisément clients qui
pour n'est pas par hasard que jean marie
le pen venir à vichy le jour de la plus
grande fête juive de l'année c'est pour
remuer les démons du passé
il l'a déjà fait il ya quelques jours à
lyon en invitant à son meeting un ancien
officier allemand de la waffen ss ce qui
a obligé le maire de lyon a annulé la
réunion bien aujourd'hui c'est pareil je
conçois que ma décision aujourd'hui peut
entraîner peut-être quelques polémiques
mais je préfère de loin quelques
polémiques à ce qui se passerait si je
laissais faire ce meeting la fausse note
mais de taille vient de nice jacques
médecin qui accueille le congrès du
front national dont l'invité d'honneur
n'était autre que french and über
c'était il est vrai avant carpentras et
dans une lettre ouverte publiée
aujourd'hui par l'hebdomadaire vsd
jacques chirac lance un appel aux hommes
politiques aux jeunes et à l'ensemble
des français pour qu'ils rejettent
solennellement la xénophobie en gaz et
vous engagez vous messieurs sachez que
ce slogan n'est plus mais alors plus du
tout à l'ordre du jour l'armée française
envisage même une diminution globale de
50 mille personnes au sein de ses
effectifs et le passage du service
militaire de 12 à 10 mois une réduction
importante qui semble le prouver qu'on a
moins besoin de militaires en france
pourquoi
réponse avec pierre babey scène de la
vie ordinaire dans une caserne française
s'est appelée font leurs classes ils
passeront 12 mois sous les drapeaux
question combien leurs cadets feront ils
de service dans quelques années
réponse un certain temps assurément un
peu moins
plus sérieusement les gros bataillons
c'est fini les armes et ne peut plus
absorber des classes de contingents
pléthorique inutile trop cher trop cher
parce qu'il faut tout à la fois tenir
les promesses de la loi de programmation
fabriquer les nouveaux équipements est
entré dans un budget simplement
reconduits 290 milliards de francs 91
inutile parce que les armées est
particulièrement l'armée terre doivent
retrouver un format plus resserrée des
armements oblige
hors de question de faire dégager des
cadres l'armée a déjà maigri de 15% en
quelques années
reste une solution diminuer le nombre
d'appelés simultanément sous les
drapeaux donc réduire la durée du
service dernière formule envisagée un
service as dix mois plus de mois
d'initiation à la vie professionnelle
mais pas forcément en kaki le président
sud- africaine de clair que tient ses
promesses l'abolition de l'apartheid
entre dans les faits jusqu'à présent les
hôpitaux publics était interdit aux
noirs ne sont plus marqué mon la couleur
de la peau ne sera plus un critère de
sélection des malades en l'afrique du
sud c'est officiel depuis ce matin
l'apartheid dans les hôpitaux est abolie
c'est le ministre de la santé qui l'a
annoncé et les 240 hôpitaux du secteur
public seront enfin ouvert à la
population sud africaine dans son
ensemble
la situation devenait insupportable dans
le seul hôpital général de johannesburg
qui était réservé aux blancs seuls 50 %
des lits étaient occupés
tandis que des centaines de malades noir
devait coucher à même le sol dans le
seul hôpital pour les noirs de soweto
la décision du gouvernement de frederik
de klerk prolonge dans la vie
quotidienne des sud africains les
négociations qu'il avait mené tout
récemment avec la nc et nelson mandela
prochaine étape vers l'abolition totale
de la politique de ségrégation raciale
de l'afrique du sud les écoles qui
seront prochainement ouvertes à tous les
enfants quelle que soit la couleur de
leur proof
reste à savoir comment ces mesures anti
apartheid seront accueillis est vécu par
la population et en particulier par la
minorité blanche
l'allemagne de l'ouest et l'allemagne de
l'est sont aujourd'hui plus discrète
dans leur lune de miel
elle en parle moins mais elles agissent
le traité d'état instaurant l'union
économique et monétaire est bouclée sera
signé demain
mais la nouvelle allemagne raconte l ex
union soviétique moscou a suspendu
aujourd'hui le retrait de ses troupes de
rda c'est manifestement un geste
politique
le kremlin veut des garanties sur le
statut de la nouvelle allemagne
cela illustre un certain eddy cement de
gorbatchev face à l'ouest en roumanie à
trois jours des élections tous les
sondages dans l'yonne signé ce coup
comme largement majoritaires même si ces
sondages ne sont pas toujours très
fiable le leader du front de salut
national est apparemment très soutenue
notamment à bucarest où plus de 60% des
électeurs seraient prêts à voter pour
lui portrait de l'homme qui deviendra
sans doute dimanche le nouveau numéro un
roumain un reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux philippe piste à et marc do
youn iliescu le 22 décembre 89
nous sommes au siège du comité central
chercher secours viennent s'enfuir le
front de salut national se constitue
iliescu est au premier rang
depuis il n'a pas quitté le pouvoir
aujourd'hui les golan de la place de
l'université en ont fait leur cible
favorite
le président roumain aurait volé la
révolution profiter de l'étincelle
populaire pour s'installer au pouvoir
iliescu accusée de néo communisme et de
cette compromis avec chercher ce coup né
en 1930 famille de tradition communiste
ingénieurs hydro technicien de formation
l'homme
il est vrai est un produit du sérail
toute une carrière au sein du pc des
jeunesses communistes à la présidence de
l'association des étudiants communistes
canton la disgrâce
il est alors secrétaire du comité
central ils l'expliquent à la télévision
et sur les 971 mark napier avait
ceausescu
j'avais alors des responsabilités au
sein du pouvoir on jouait au comité
central
j'ai filmé blâmer un accusé
d'intellectualisme il y ait ce coup
s'oppose aux dictateurs qui de retour de
chine entend appliquer une mini
révolution culturelle en roumanie
progressivement la disgrâce du père
postes et fonctions il se retrouve
simple directeur d'une petite maison
d'édition
quand éclate la révolte loin des gaules
année de leur accusation millions
communisme la grande masse des roumains
pour elle iliescu égale révolution fin
de l'escalavage et elle le montre dans
les meetings
il est molle et le peuple je prends la
roumanie ses détracteurs disent qu'il
est communiste qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
pire il a été communiste a mais je crois
que il s'agit d'une rupture non à un
homme d'un sapin c'est dans sa pontiac
nom des années de culte de la
personnalité créer des habitudes
mais aujourd'hui la ferveur et spontanée
pour ces gens les autres candidats sont
des étrangers
la majorité désorienté des roumains se
cherche un père la cécité et ses
traumatismes c'est l'objet d'un colloque
de psychiatrie qui se tient en ce moment
même à paris
mais les psychiatres ne veulent pas
désespérer ceux qui ne voient pas où je
ne vois plus mais il met en avant un
exemple celui d'un comédien qui a perdu
la vie s'il ya dix ans et qui tient à
rester sur les planches
une vraie leçon de courage reportage à
noron gère et christian de carnets
jusqu'avant déterminé et sûr de lui il
dirige ses comédiens mais ils ne les
voient pas un matin bruno né terre s'est
réveillée aveugle c'était il y a dix ans
tumeur au cerveau après une phase de
dépression
il a voulu reprendre sa vie comme avant
comme avant il prend le métro pour aller
au théâtre mais maintenant c'est par la
mémoire qui suit les trajets station par
station
et là il va au dos
se trouver
et ça y est la victoire
dans le métro bruno se repère au bruit
de la foule et à l'écho de ses propres
pas au théâtre c'est plus difficile au
sol quelques repères quadrille décor
mais il faut un bon repérage pour
trouver ses marques
bruno enfermé dans sa nuit mais attentif
toujours les yeux ouverts et le regard
dirigé vers celui des comédiens comme
pendant l'interview quand vous discutez
avec quelqu'un vous le regarder droit
dans les yeux
alors pourquoi moi qui ne vous voit
qu'ils ne vous voit pas je ne le
regarderai pas dans les yeux parce que
vous avez besoin de cet échange vous
essayez de me regarder dans les yeux moi
aussi bas d'une certaine façon j'essaie
de vous redonner cet échange un autre
regard direct mais vide clair elle aussi
aveugle depuis dix ans images
surréalistes
elle se maquille elle même comme avant
dans la pièce claire m bruno mais elle
veut lui cacher qu'elle est un meuble
des mains de 2 me de ben e ils vont me
dire si vous avez des mondes 15 jeux de
l'amour et de la peur jeu de miroir
entre la fiction et la réalité
cette pièce elle et elle montre des gens
qui nécessitait intérieur en fait un qui
ne veulent pas se regarder même à garder
ce qui est autour et la cécité que tout
le monde peut avoir et qui est tout à
fait autre chose que le fait de ne pas
voir un jour tu choisis la vérité de la
nuit
rappelle toi de moi antonio est clair ou
le théâtre comme de son devis des poètes
les aveugles borgès disait être aveugle
ce n'est pas un handicap
c'est une façon de vivre je vous le
disais au début de ce journal un jeune
homme armé a pris en otage deux
magistrats au palais de justice de metz
se trouve notre correspondant bernard
derty bernard vous avez des
oui la situation a passablement évolué à
présent puisque les policiers viennent à
l'instant même de faire dégager la foule
qui s'était agglutinée autour de ce
palais de justice
ils viennent de mettre à disposition du
jeune preneur d'otage 1h09 beige on
pense qu'il devrait quitter ce palais de
justice dans les quelques minutes à
venir on ne sait qui prime ce palais de
justice avec ou sans les otages
tout ce que je puis vous dire pour
l'instant c'est que les policiers ont
revêtu leurs brassards et qu'on
s'apprête à peut-être connaître un début
de dénouement dans cette affaire écuries
clame-t-il précisément barre et bien ils
réclament la liberté de sa petite amie
et miller et qui était interrogé par les
juges pour enfants
il réclamait sa liberté on vous
retrouvera sans doute au cours de ce 19
20 ou à la fin de ce 19 à nice tout de
suite les autres faits marquants de
l'actualité en france grâce aux images
de nos stations régionales commentaires
fasquelle justice le tueur aujourd'hui à
nanterre du 33e congrès de la fédération
cgt de la métallurgie dans son discours
henri krasucki a accusé le gouvernement
de pratiquer une politique patronale le
gouvernement rpt cas at il déclaré
aurait fait avec renault ce que celui de
chirac n'avait pas osé faire
dupuis
opération ville morte aujourd'hui à
morteau dans le doubs la municipalité
organise cette opération en solidarité
avec les salariés de l'horlogerie depuis
le début de l'année cinq entreprises ont
déjà fermé leurs portes dans ce secteur
clé de l'économie locale 450 emplois
sont menacés
un agent des impôts mais un dirigeant de
l'office national des vins ont été
inculpé aujourd'hui à montpellier pour
escroquerie corruption et abus de
confiance
on leur reproche des malversations qui
porterait sur des primes d'arrachage les
pots-de-vin s'élèverait à 300 mille
francs
la cogema vient de sortir un détecteur
de radeaux pour grand public
le radon est un gaz faiblement
radioactifs qui peut s'infiltrer dans
les maisons par le sol à l'origine
l'appareil est utilisé dans les mines
d'uranium
mais aux états unis les particuliers se
l'arrachent dugast maxime francs pour
rassurer les inquiets
il a fallu deux heures et 80 peau qui
est ce matin au bourget pour éteindre
l'incendié qui s'est déclaré dans un
entrepôt du musée de l'air et de
l'espace
20 avions de collection ont été détruits
dont un fighting cet appareil avec
lequel sa fille du périph a disparu en
1940 qu'un très beau cadeau
d'anniversaire pour jean denis bredin le
célèbre avocat et écrivain a fêté
aujourd'hui ses 61 ans à l'académie
française où il succède à marguerite
yourcenar
véronique bonnet n'aura bon anniversaire
nos voeux les plus sincères que ce jour
20 que vous apporte
que l'année entière soit douce et légère
monsieur morts mon cher jean denis soyez
le bienvenu parmi vos pairs et vos amis
j'en ai libre d'un 61 ans aujourd'hui le
même âge que son ami et voisin devant
bertrand poirot-delpech ils ont l'air de
potache qui se réjouissent de la
bonhomie de pierre moinot qui conclut sa
réponse de façon si incongrue sous la
coupole des immortels avec eux avec jean
pierre angremy et jean d'ormesson
la moyenne d'âge des académiciens
remonte nettement et ses fils ancien
dans le ton et l'écriture du discours de
jean denis bredin remercie pour cet
amateur d'objets que vous avez conviés à
regarder de près une épée à la touche et
même pour la première fois une épée
imaginé pour de mystérieux emploi pour
faire reculer la sottise pour découper
les livres ou simplement pour aider à se
tenir son visage ridé son corps épaissi
enveloppé dans une grande robe de
chambre exprime une souveraineté qui
tient à distance un éloge très vivant et
106 son prédécesseur marguerite
yourcenar décidément une nouvelle
musique sous la coupole
fabrice à 20h eddy mitchell et clint
eastwood à 20h30 marque hautement à
22h30 pour les infos tout de suite la
météo complexe de fluence khl et les
informations sur la prise d'otages
évidemment à 22h30 bonsoir à demain 19h
à